kostenloser nahverkehr gibt es schon mit
der schwarz fahrkarte kostenloser
nahverkehr gibt es schon mit der schwarz
fahrkarte kostenloser nahverkehr gibt es
schon mit der schwarzer kater leute ich
glaube ich bin einfach nicht gemacht für
werbung
[Musik]
melbourne hattest aline auch kostenlosen
nahverkehr
wir machen diese städte dieses wunder
möglich
tallinn erlaubt nur tallinn an eine
kostenlose fahrt das hat dazu geführt
dass mehr leute sich in der stadt
registriert haben höhere steuereinnahmen
durch mehr offizielle stadtbewohner
unter dem strich sagen beide städte dass
sie sogar ein plus machen
die frage ist könnte kostenloser
nahverkehr auch in deutschland
funktionieren was die frage ist
bescheuert natürlich funktioniert ist
okay ach so das video muss mindestens
drei minuten lang werden
270.000 menschen werden jedes jahr in
deutschland beim schwarzfahren erwischt
das sind fast so viele menschen wie
bielefeld einwohner hat das gibt es doch
gar nicht was bielefeld nein dass so
viele menschen beim schwarzfahren
erwischt werden
die mehrheit der schwarzfahrer macht das
nicht aus spaß sondern aus armut sei
denn man ist nur zum spaß am aber dass
armut eine entscheidung ist glauben
höchstens fdp wähler zwar gibt es in
deutsch land sozialtickets aber der
rabatt reicht nicht im hartz iv
regelsatz sind 34 eur 66 für verkehr
vorgesehen
in hamburg kostet die ermäßigte
monatskarte aber zum beispiel 85 eur 30
arschkarte stadt fahrkarte es ist in
deutschland möglich dass man sich die 1
euro 50 für die kurzwahl karte nicht
leisten kann dann 60 euro strafe zahlen
muss weil man das erst recht nicht
zahlen kann ins gefängnis kommt und der
staat dann 150 euro pro tag pro häftling
ausgibt das ist meine preissteigerung
so und jetzt ein witz
unterhalten sich drei häftlinge sagt der
erste ich habe jemanden ermordet sagt
der zweite ich habe jemanden ausgeraubt
sagt der dritte
ich konnte mir meine fahrkarte nicht
leisten das ist ein scheiß witz für die
geschätzten 100 milliarden euro steuern
die in deutschland jährlich hinterzogen
werden könnte man auch den öffentlichen
nahverkehr zehnmal finanzieren
man könnte statt fahrkartenkontrolleure
auch einfach steuerfahnder einstellen
logisch jemand der deutschland nutzt
ohne dafür zu zahlen sollte bestraft
werden
dieser abschnitt war jetzt extrem
populistisch aber steckt nicht in jedem
populismus auch ein bisschen wahrheit
nein
trotzdem hier stimmt warum zahle ich für
theater mit wenn ich da selbst gar nicht
hingehe
warum zahle ich für den
verfassungsschutz mit wenn ich gar kein
nazi bin wenn ich glück habe werde ich
in meinem leben niemals auf hilfe von
feuerwehr krankenhäusern oder vom
jobcenter angewiesen sein
aber ich finde es gut dass es das gibt
umgekehrt könnte man es natürlich auch
machen wenn schon der öffentliche
nahverkehr geld kostet dann könnte man
auch geld nehmen für das benutzen einer
ampel oder einer schaukel wie teuer ist
zb stau für die gesellschaft der adac
beziffert die indirekten und direkten
kosten von stau auf 79 8 milliarden euro
das sind fast 60 milliarden euro mehr
als der gesamte öffentliche nahverkehr
in deutschland kostet auf 3,5 metern
straße können pro stunde 2000 menschen
in autos befördert werden
die straßenbahn transportiert im
gleichen zeitraum 22 1000 passagiere
autoverkehr ist also aus sicht der
allgemeinheit nicht nur die teuerste
form der fortbewegung sondern auch noch
die dümmste fazit schwarzfahren muss
bezahlbar bleiben